[Laughter]
[Music]
when i was
just out of college i read this book
called girdle escherbach an eternal
golden braid by douglas hofstetter
the book is about the phenomenon of
intelligence and how it emerges
from the brain and also how we might
implement
intelligence in machines and it just
changed my life because it showed me
that i
wanted to go into artificial
intelligence
i work kind of at the intersection of ai
and cognitive science
and complex systems i'm interested in
how we humans are able to think
abstractly and make analogies that is to
be able to
perceive or recognize two different
situations
as being essentially similar and in an
abstract level
and then to ask how can we give that
ability to machines
how can we make a machine recognize an
analogy
this is something that's really i think
the missing link in artificial
intelligence
we have computers that can recognize
objects they can
drive cars to some extent they can play
games like chess and go
at levels beyond humans but they can't
do the
simplest thing that even say a
two-year-old child can do
which is to fluidly and flexibly
generalize
what they've learned to new situations
that's something i'm
interested in figuring out how to get
machines to do that
one of the important features of
intelligence
is being able to have a kind of internal
model
of the world and to be able to simulate
that model to predict what's going to
happen
so whenever i interact with anybody i
can sort of predict
to some extent what they're going to do
or how they're going to react to certain
other things
and this is because i i have us models
of how the world works and how other
people work
this is something that for instance a
self-driving car is going to need
to be able to predict say what a
pedestrian is going to do
whenever you have these constrained
domains then
machines can often do quite well in them
but
when you have the real world and
open-ended situations
that's where what we might call common
sense comes into play and that's
something that machines
lack analogy is the way we deal with
novelty that occurs all the time
without making analogies which we do
unconsciously
all the time we can't really do things
that we haven't encountered before
until we get machines to make analogies
they're not going to be
trustworthy or flexible enough to deal
with
the real world in the way that we do at
the very beginning of ai
it was well integrated with other
disciplines like
psychology neuroscience philosophy but
as ai kind of moved away from approaches
that were inspired by
these other disciplines it relied much
more on statistics
and less from trying to imitate the
mechanisms that
biologically intelligent systems use
it's
almost like it's a victim of its own
success it's been so successful that
people haven't
needed to go back to the fundamentals of
intelligence of the science of
intelligence but now it seems like deep
learning deep neural networks
are reaching a kind of a limit in what
they can do
so people are now thinking maybe we
should look back at
things like developmental psychology how
do children learn or
feedback in the brain something that's
extremely important that is completely
lacking in most neural networks
so i think that it's really important
that we now bring
back into ai some of these earlier ideas
about
intelligence and what makes a system
truly intelligent
you